I will win the Hispanic vote
there are Trump pinatas being hit right
now what he thought about bad okay what
does that say about how they're also
people calling me all the time saying
you're right by now we all know what
Donald Trump thinks about immigrants
he's speaking here at a conservative
summit in the battleground state of Iowa
so we're gonna ask Republicans their
thoughts on immigration and then we're
gonna drive to the state's first
majority Latino town
thank Mexico is pushing mostly
undesirables towards us they don't want
so do you know any Mexicans I do know a
few actually yes
are they desirable I think they are they
came legally do Trump's views about
immigration represent you necessarily
Jeff elysium is more of an entertainer
than a politician I'm in a construction
field and I know some people that have
Mexicans in voidform there's some
doggone good hard-working young men that
are in the construction field so my
statement would be do it right if your
goal is to come and improve yourself and
improve your family do it right
Iowa is 92 percent white but in West
Liberty Latinos make up 52% of the
population studies have shown there's
basically no correlation between violent
crime and immigrants and yet Trump said
what he said and he rises in a told what
does that say about the American
sporting I feel like if you just look
back at history
so if you find a scapegoat Latinos right
escape oh yeah
first I would say for this presidential
election yet I think that was very
racist up in everybody you know we work
hard I think everybody worked hard to be
where they're at he thinks he'd win the
Hispanic vote would you vote for him no
do you know anyone in your community
that one pays esta si como esta go
hispanos hispana
que somos el t no important trabajo
Louis MO oh my dad you taught me how to
work you know the hard work and he well
he wanted me to go to college and
everything but it was gonna hard for him
because he was very starting getting you
know his future here what did he do
construction what do you do construction
it doesn't matter of your if you're
black white Mexican when you were
construction you built your building
America